the crying person that is interviewing
with the Lord's love I'm carless very
nice to meet you nice to meet you Carlos
tell us about Amber time I pronouncing
it correctly
very very particular game yeah let me
let me show you a little bit of the yeah
let me show you a little bit of the
beginning of the game so Heinrich it's a
very particular game it's probably
something like you've never seen before
okay so like that thank you thank you
very much so I came up this weird idea
about making a difference story base
game
literally you can see the words are the
seven ball okay so it's like a book so
there's a door on top of the word door
right in order to open the key right and
you grab okay
with a key you can open the door
simple enough
so we tried to mix a lot of Jerez into
this game it's not only a puzzle and we
also get a story so this is the word
world
okay so you enter this word world where
you're the floor or the words of the
story but after you beat the pure
purpose in the world world to get out of
it and get into the real world okay so
this is just one like the titanium is
not my business
gotcha section of the game China third
even the only mechanic that we're
missing until see how the game changes
the mechanic possibly
these are the mechanics
[ __ ] understanding
the puzzle identity
what specifically change so for instance
here yeah it gives that muscle concept
here but it's more action
so you will face the soldier
grab a sword and you can fight it
so it now takes something else aside of
your
solving skills it's more of your action
so we are possible and we got action
and even the Marcin teachers
this is not just because you have to
soar
that's it it's all know so that his name
is out yes it's very miserable the noise
like you
while you can't see this member
the prison now that you think that you
kind of understand how it plays we try
to change the pace
so the nurse archers backhoe
[Music]
to grab crossbow
always behind it the defense nice
actually it becomes a first-person
shooter now
so should like you would in a
first-person shooter
- oh nice - when we talk about the
mechanics changes yes okay
that's though
let's go I like
no one's looking out for ps4 Xbox one
and PC I mean if we get you know we're
trying to work for a stretched version
but it will probably come out later yeah
yeah we are trying to but for now
confirmed ps4 PC and it's really soon
it's on June 6th yeah yes and the game
is completely ready it's around 6 hours
of gameplay and it's a really long story
it's a pretty interesting story depicted
know who I brigades but innovations are
what his dreams are he's this very
worrisome character is ascribed
fantastic so it's all about that I
should get to be the king he's elite
force to be warrior
Oh Lord loss
yeah
yes
yeah
yes
there you guys and as you can see
oh no point in the blood it's Philly
so when
and after this
I really
they fight about
on Norway Wow
you got oh now
[Music]
this is crazy
[Music]
cause you what don't we have a racer
soon
that's right is it a racers rabbit
enemies in a row actually we have we got
all of the game actually we have an
endless-runner type of sequence just
can't like a racing so we do get chased
by an enemy nice every go and as you can
see you have this story mode
so we just come out June 16
before before you before
thank you thank you very much oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
yes
not Henry well crown thank you thank you
so much I did it oh my god no oh my god
I can die now I can die now